okay cool well I'm glad we're good
people and weren't saying anything bad
wouldn't that be careful
if we like showed up we're like gosh
we're doing this again
geez you know what's the greatest part I
literally marked off my calendar like my
uh resolution for the year which is to
get Adam onto the podcast so we did it
we did it is that a resolution or like a
bucket list kind of thing both you know
yeah well we're gonna be alive so might
as well put it on the bucket list
true that
dang
so we're live we're just don't have
sound effects
it's so sad
all right all right
is that the sound effect
s
it sounds like that's pretty good
how unfortunate but y'all y'all watching
y'all can hear us
and um
so I guess that's the most important
part
is that they can hear us talking
and then yeah the sound well we have
Adam to do the sound effect live I guess
that's the point
um
but I'm going to uh I'm gonna hit the
sound effect button
and let us know in the comments if you
hear this
okay so we'll see
but um
I just updated this streaming software
and I think I was supposed to restart it
before
[Music]
oh that'll that'll mess up for sure
yeah so that's on me fam that's on me
it's all good no no sound effect it's
awesome it's not the first time it won't
be the last it's all good and the good
part is it's like you know this is this
is all part of the process this is our
first time having a guest on in a while
of course you know there's got to be
something that happens
and the one thing in my rider was there
has to be sound effects
yeah exactly
only green M M's
so anyway so we are doing it
it's all good peeps we thank you all for
hanging out here we actually promoted
this one so it'll be interesting to see
if um
we get more peeps in here
[Music]
but uh
uh what we're gonna do here
um is uh we're gonna give some joke
feedback we're gonna
talk to Adam about his comedy special
and
all the cool things he has going on
and then um we'll get Yoshi's family
update
I'm talking as if we're not live right
now I'm like talking as if we're like
still off air like all right so here's
what we're gonna do today
but it's literally
okay so people are already posting jokes
so do post your jokes in the live chat
friends
um
just be sure to put the word joke in
front of it
so when no
to uh read it live on the air
and uh we see chance posted a joke Zab
posted one
Harold posted one okay cool
so we're gonna get into it here wasalla
wasalu
he actually posted the first one
um
but how are you gents doing first off we
have yoshiso and Adam Mueller
how are y'all doing this is so
professional I feel like we should just
I feel like we have to just start all
the way over and act like none of this
happened we're gonna try again next week
uh
you know the only one who's in your own
head about this you sound great this is
amazing like I didn't see anything yeah
it looks great I look great like a
professional you know what I mean like
we're we're good dude you just
compliment yourself
yeah always okay
you don't know me by now humble is not
something that I struggle with you know
what I'm saying all right I like that
yeah
I was about to say you look good and
then you said it yourself so I didn't
have to do
beautiful I am doing well uh gents um
yeah just came back from dropping off
the kiddos excited to be here
um had a fun weekend I featured all
weekend so I did four shows it was great
like leveled it up each show and it was
just a fun fun weekend man so you know
it was a good comedy weekend I can't
complain it's the kind of weekend I want
to have more of
Amen to that did you have a good comedy
weekend Adam
oh I had like the best like week that
I've probably ever had yeah what yeah
yeah
um I was down in uh and down in Sarasota
featuring but it was um it was Wednesday
through Sunday so seven shows so nice
just
the like doing seven 25 minute sets in
five days your ability to just make
adjustments and just
each show it's just getting better and
better and better
and then the seventh show ends and you
can start crying because it's over
and even if even if they're like we'll
get off work we'll definitely bring you
back you know that they can only bring
you back like once a year so you're like
seeing see you in 2024 for sure um but
no it was awesome it was so it was great
great crowds they pat all the shows were
packed uh-huh does that it's like my
favorite thing about that stuff like
they just know how to pack the crowd and
they oh yeah they're early too aren't
they they're like at seven
Wednesday and Thursday were seven and
then Friday and Saturday the early show
was 6 30 in the late show was 8 50.
I love that and then Sunday it was
Sunday it was at seven again during the
second football game
and it was still almost sold out it was
insane oh my yeah yeah what was the club
it was uh McCurdy's in Sarasota oh oh
that's great that's one that's an OG
Club there yeah yeah the average age was
a hundred and um
the crowds were great they were great
Joe Biden and his friends
like it is it is up there
dude congrats yeah getting that feature
road work is the next that's that next
step we were like oh I'm doing we're
doing it here
yeah yeah
um and it was good to get you know it
was an example of like perseverance
paying off because I I was first there
for like a World Series of comedy thing
in probably 2018
.
um maybe or maybe 2019 but like I got to
the finals the booker saw me they liked
me they said like keep in touch you know
well and I sent emails and then I saw
the booker at the World Series Main
Event in Vegas and I'd never heard a
response to any email so I went up to
introduce myself and I'm like hey
I'm Adam I'm a New York based comic she
goes oh I know who you are I get your
emails
[Laughter]
and I don't read them and then she was
like just keep sending them and I'm like
well how I don't want to I don't want to
be uh annoying how often would you like
me to send and she goes no matter even
if you don't hear from me every month
send me your avails and so I just kept
doing it and then uh you know whenever
it was uh a month ago out of the blue
email pops up from her can you come this
weekend Wednesday to Sunday seven shows
here are the details and uh luckily I
only had I only had some City spots that
were easy to kind of move around and I
could make it make it work
but it was just yeah just you know it
was a year and a half of emails and then
it hits and then hopefully
you kind of get to go once a year now
you know yeah but that's one out of the
52. and then you know another 52 years
now you're booked up
yeah I just need 20 or 30 clubs to do
that yeah and then you're good
and you do you do well there and then
you're more likely to get referred by
them as well so
well it also looks good and like you
know sometimes you sometimes um you go
to a club's website because you want to
reach out for Feature work or whatever
and they have like very explicit
instructions like there's one club that
they're like I want to know send us an
email with you know with a 30 minute
tape with a list of everywhere you've
featured for the last 12 months who the
headliner was and what you have on your
calendar for the next 12 months so it
feels really um
it it doesn't feel good when you don't
have anything to put in that email right
so once you start get but once you can
start saying some clubs and some
Headliners that are doing well and that
are that have maybe been on TV recently
that people might know
like yeah then it starts creating some
momentum so it's nice
yeah for the hour the hour helps as well
being able to link in like here's an
hour
oh to your set yeah with your YouTube
special yeah
which is great I have a second version
of it that's that's just the head-on
camera with no edits mm-hmm
and it's like you watch what you know
the specials whatever 56 minutes that
the head-on camera beginning to end is
maybe 62 minutes
scroll to wherever you want watch watch
whatever you know watch the whole thing
watch any 30 seconds I don't care
here it is and um and that's helpful to
have you know
yeah and you really followed uh and I
was headline Aurora Theater all weekend
I don't want to act like that you are
the only two out here working but I was
about to not ask you how your weekend
was yeah
we had a great we had a great uh great
weekend
um it's a good reminder we still got it
I hadn't headlined in a minute uh
headline this year so
um I was I was not concerned but I was
you know nervous going into it and it
all went well
um awesome
so yeah so we're available for bookings
anyone listening to this that's really
what this is we want to make comedians
super dope so then they book us on their
super dope shows that's basically what
we're doing here so
but you you've really done what like
this like new wave of Comedy is where
you like you self-produce a comedy
special and you put it on YouTube so
like what is what what has this
experience been like for you because
we're all seeing these comedians do this
but what's what's it like behind behind
the scenes to do that whole thing
um I mean first of all like it was it
was very fun like there was there's you
know it's stressful I guess a little bit
but um
it's if you think I think if you think
about it the right way it's not as
stressful as you think it might be only
because you don't have to do anything
with it
right like you know you can you you you
put a you put a stake in the ground and
you say like you know June 2nd I'm doing
a show I'm gonna do an hour I'm gonna
bring in
a video crew and and make sure we
capture the audio and capture the video
and then if if it goes terribly
you're gonna end up with some weird
Instagram clips and maybe that's it and
if it goes really well you then you have
something and and decide what you want
to do with it and how much of it you
want to put out
um and if you know you don't you don't
have to but
I think in my case you know it went
really well we were able to to we only
took three or four minutes out and um
frankly a bunch of what we took out was
just uh
there's like three minutes near the at
the beginning about like of like kind of
covet jokes and as I was reviewing the
final edit and just thinking about where
the world was like no one wants to hear
this anymore
um and I don't want to open with stuff
that makes this feel like dated
because someone might turn it off so
let's just cut that out
um and uh and then the rest is kind of
is what it is and then we had to we had
to cut a little bit in the middle
because a woman got mad and left what
kerfuffle
um
yeah you know I'm a very controversial
uh those Canadian jokes really get very
divisive yeah very divisive yeah she got
uh she got upset had to be escorted out
it was great I actually kind of liked it
but um we took it out and that's on
camera though
uh we don't I mean you can hear it you
can certainly hear her on the audio but
uh
and I noticed something was going on I
made a little joke about it which I
thought I wanted to keep it in because I
thought the Riff was funny but the uh
the guy that was editing it was like
yeah I just take that out you don't want
that in you can always post it on you
can always post it later
separately
um
and uh and I did it kind of I did it I
did it uh inexpensively in that I I knew
I had some I know some comedians that
also kind of have a production company
and uh they were willing to kind of
bring their nice camera in and film and
then the club I was at has a really nice
house camera
that I kind of taught myself how to use
and then I uh instead of paying to bring
in a crew I paid to buy a third camera
that's a nice camera that I can now
carry around and use when you know for
all of my sets and that was kind of
those are the three main cameras and
then I just scrounged around and got
three or four other
little cameras and just put them places
just in case they captured something and
we ended up using footage from some of
them and then uh you know and then you
plug into the sound board you get the
audio you put a bunch of Zoom mics in
the room or Zoom recorders and uh
and if you get those in the hands of a
good
you know editor
and a good uh sound engineer they can
they can
work their magic and it'll sound and
look great
um did you use
and did you write any other elements
like did you add any like a lighting or
anything like production wise so tell us
right just outside of the camera work
what else did you make it pop
so I can tell you I'll tell you exactly
what I did and then I'll tell you what I
would do if I was doing it again um
which would be slightly different but so
I had the three really good you know 4K
cameras to uh for for people that that
care two of them were black magic
uh cameras and one was a Sony a74 and
those were like the three main
shots that you shot in like raw and
s-log footage that they could color
correct and do all their magic on in
post-production and then I had um
another Sony camera a Lumix camera
um just put in the room at like strange
angles and then I put I hung a GoPro I
hit a GoPro on the stage looking at the
crowd
and uh and turn that on and you can see
there's some crowd shots from that that
worked out pretty well
um
and I didn't know if that would be be
usable at all and it turned out it was
so that that was the kind of the cameras
and then we put um I mean every camera
had uh some sort of uh shotgun mic or
other audio capture and you know
associated with it but then we had two
Zoom recorders in the room in different
spots
um and then the club has one audience
mic just in the like in the ceiling just
hanging down
um
and really to what we we got really
lucky in that a lot of the a lot of the
audio didn't work very well like a lot
of it peaked or had issues but one of
the zoom recorders got it
and all we needed was that one Zoom
recorder and the the mics feed from the
sound board and that and it worked we
but it was that close to having nothing
you know
yeah
come on back up on backup on backup yeah
that's legit and the biggest thing I
would do if I did and we did not do any
extra lighting
like we just went with the club's
lighting
um one thing if I if I did it again I I
do think
um the the guy that edited it and
directed it would have also been willing
to film it and I think if I did it again
I'd love I'd just get I'd have him do it
all which would cost me more
um and I also think you can't have
enough Zoom recorders or other you can't
have enough audio capture in the room
I would I would triple the number of
audio digital audio recorders in the
room if I did it again just because you
never know
and if you um and everyone's gonna work
what's not going to work and I've
learned a little bit more about the
settings they should be on Etc so they
don't Peak
and so that you make sure you get usable
audio
yeah
um that's the big yeah doing a master
class on how to record a YouTube special
nice dude and you got to know you got to
know where the speakers are in the room
and you've got to point the audio kind
of mics so that to try to minimize the
amount of the speaker they're getting
right because if they capture you at the
mic too loud when you try to layer that
with the mic feed it can be it can sound
sort of hollow and you get like an echo
or a tinny thing
um I mean in an ideal world you just
have you on the mic and you have the
audience
and that'll be it thanks to but you
can't because obviously they have to
hear you like there's a you know but if
you if you put a shotgun mic like if a
speaker's pointing this way you put I
gotta figure you put the shotgun mic
like right beside it pointing the same
way so that so you don't want the shock
I'm like pointing at the speaker if that
makes sense
um
so things like that and just
understanding the room that you're
recording in will help you and I'm sure
look there's audio Engineers that are
probably like duh yeah
but I didn't know I didn't I didn't
thought about any of that
uh also don't put it don't put a zoom
Recorder near the air conditioner we
learned that one the hard way
it's like you can't get rid of that hum
when the air conditioner turns off
you know we did it in June so the air
conditioners are on the whole uh
the whole show so things like that
that's funny unless you wanted to do a
sounded like Darth Vader or something
just yeah
and turn off the frozen margarita
machine that's another tip oh hilarious
that'll that'll mess with the uh sound a
little bit
which they did by the way we did no
problems with the margarita machine they
were like they uh they even unplugged
there's a bar in the room where I did it
in the club like there's the there's and
they unplugged all the refrigerators and
everything for this like for my set so
that there was no you know we'd really
tried to minimize it there the air
conditioner was really the only issue
yeah and we stupidly had one of our Zoom
recorders like right in front of the air
conditioner for some reason
and that one was useless but yeah how
did you pick the venue or I'm sorry
Yoshi yes that's a good question that
was a good question it's mine was
related to exactly that yeah
so I think the venue was um
uh I um
they were they were a venue that was
willing to give me a Thursday
and some of the clubs and some of the
clubs like I might have had a chance to
record there but I would have had a
Sunday or a Monday kind of a thing right
they give you an off night
um which makes sense but at uh west side
is willing to give me a Thursday like
eight o'clock kind of show and
I I if I looked at the prior couple
months I knew they were getting like 40
to 50 people
for their Thursday show anyway
the club seats about like say a hundred
so I was like oh so if I get 50 that
and they get their regular Thursday
night crowd I just sold the room out
um whereas if I do a Monday somewhere I
gotta get all 100 myself you know what I
mean
so um and a Thursday night's a good it's
a good comedy night
um it's not like in New York a lot of
people leave on the weekends in June so
Friday's tough
um for people that I know that I would
want you know that you want to come like
support and stuff so Thursday was part
Thursday eight o'clock was perfect the
downside was I only did one show so it
had to all go perfectly
yeah so the two things I would love if I
did it again would be to have two shows
and to have someone out like I was
literally playing with cameras 45
seconds before I went on stage
it would be nice to just be sitting in a
green room looking at your notes and
then get to go on instead of having to
worry about all the other stuff
oh dude when when I filmed mine the
camera on stage wasn't
um set up yet so we we did this whole
intro I go out there it's the big hero
welcoming and then that camera wasn't
set up yet and we had to reset the
entire thing and we had to act like that
didn't happen
I wanted some of that footage right I
left I left that footage yeah and um I
forgot my jokes at one time because I
did it all on one take I mean one taping
as well and in hindsight I filmed it
without really having done that many 45
minute sets so it's like there were so
many things going on there that in
hindsight I'm like oh yeah this would
have been better that could have done
that but I think just climbing that
mountain and just doing it I think is a
big thing in a milestone for every comic
getting it done and if it doesn't turn
out great then like you said you know
you have some clips you don't have to
release it as a special
well I remember when someone asked me
after they're like hey Adam was that the
first time you've done that hour and I
was like that was the first time I did
an hour
like that hour
that's I mean I've constructed into five
minute increments at open mics that's
how that was built right
no one gets to practice an hour it's not
like there's an open mic where someone's
like hey you want to practice your hour
here you're really only able to like
bits of it so I remember when I was uh I
wasn't filming but I wanted to practice
an hour because I was doing an hour and
I would just do 15 minute bits at
whatever spots that I could get but
never that same 15 so I would just do
different parts of it just to get the
hour but no one gives you that hour
so for about two months for about two
months leading up to it obviously I'm
working on the jokes at every show I'm
at and you know I'm slipping in
different pieces and chunks and and I'm
getting five minute sets an occasional
15 minute set or whatever but every day
I would I have a mic and a mic stand at
home right and I would just go I would
turn on a stopwatch I'd go to the mic
and I would do the hour to a wall
every day and it after cut doing that a
couple times you want to poke your eyes
out it's horrible but
you just it starts you start getting it
in your head and you start every time
you realize like oh that that order's
wrong it just feels wrong I'm gonna do
in this other like and and I was like
that's the only thing I can do because
I'm not I'm not on the road headlining
every weekend just running my hour I
don't have that luxury and I want to do
is I want it to be as good as it can be
so that's the you know that was the
solution
for a couple months
however I took like a day off but like
it's brutal yeah
how long you been doing comedy
even the walls started booing
um no that was your neighbors yeah we've
heard that one Adam
I'm like uh I'm closing in on six years
closing in on six years yeah yeah nice
that's awesome yeah and someone asked um
and we'll get to y'all's jokes we
appreciate y'all um
uh hanging out with us and posting jokes
we'll definitely share some feedback but
we have we have Adam here
uh who just posted his YouTube special
not long ago so we want to been meaning
to have him on and we said but if we're
gonna bring on guests Adam has to be the
first one and of course now that he's
here the sound effects aren't working to
do his sound effect but we'll be sure to
bring that back next week
I had to be first so you could establish
a low bar I get it and then you can just
build from there yeah
so you're you're special You released it
about four months ago like yeah where
did you at what point did you start
seeing traction and what did you do from
a promotion perspective to get people to
watch it oh it's a great question boom
so I I uh
I I
emailed everyone that I have an email
address for to just let them know that
it existed so that's one thing
and then the club the club where I did
it at West Side
um
and they if they watch this they're
going to learn about this for the first
time but uh they have about 15 20 000
Instagram followers
so every day for a month I would um I
would DM one by one every single person
that follows the club
and I would and I had this like little
script like hey I see you're a fan of
West Side comedy club uh film my hour
there on on June 2nd it's on YouTube for
free uh give it a watch here's the link
um thanks so much for supporting comedy
you know and I and I sent that to 20 000
people or something I don't know like it
was I'll just sit there
so Savage
and just amazing that's here's the thing
I'm a marketing guy
that takes the cake on
that's like the best
one-on-one like direct to consumer
marketing that you can do it's it's very
old school gorilla no one complaining I
know there was not a single reply that
was like why'd I get this
um yeah I tried to skip Comics that I
know because that seemed like
um also because if I know them one if I
know them I've probably already reached
out in some other way and um also I
think like you get this knock-on effect
because if I do that and a bunch of
people start watching it
then the algorithm picks up that there's
people watching it and starts showing it
to more people and the whole thing you
know goes from there
um and then you know there's some
there's some some Comics you know people
are pretty supportive of stuff like that
so there's people you know when I would
uh
for the first month or so I made sure
every day like you know uh what an
Instagram story lasts 24 hours right so
I'd always make sure there was a story
with the link to it and certain Comics
would share that which was always nice
and you know you get it out there that
way
um
and I think my parents were kind of
constantly had it running at their house
like when this was a finish they just
started it again
um
they're probably still doing if I called
them now I'd probably hear it
which is hilarious
so that's fun
16 tabs open all to the special yeah oh
it's on refresh yeah
and it's wild how like once it like it
you know it's sort of built slowly for a
few days and then it just sort of took
off
um and for a month there you know
thousands of people are watching it
every day which is wild
and uh
and it's actually picked I mean and then
it drifted down over time and like and
then it's actually picked up again in
the last like a week or so
um
yeah there you go the hot breath bump
we'll see what has tomorrow
[Laughter]
we'll shoot
it's gonna it's gonna hit a million
tomorrow
um yes sir yeah I posted a link to it
also in the life oh thank you thank you
to watch it and share it we're all about
Comics helping Comics here so share it
yeah you don't even have to just turn it
on I don't care if you pay attention
good point
but someone asked
uh Jody asked
um
how much did it cost are you comfortable
saying oh yeah it's a good question Jody
I'm a comfortable part of it like I the
filming
like cost probably like 2 500 bucks or
something but that's because I bought
the camera
like
um some of the people that were there
helping me with the other cameras and
stuff were generous generously basically
donated their time and and Equipment
um and now I owe them favors but uh and
then it cost a little bit uh I'm not I'm
not supposed to say what the director
charged me because uh he cut I think he
gave me a good deal because I I like I
caught him in a Down
you know correcting these specials I
just called
like it was interesting because I'd
already set up who was going to come and
film it and stuff and then uh Jason Katz
who's the director and editor and
colorist
um just dm'd me and said hey I saw
you're promoting you're doing this thing
um and he kind of sent me his resume for
the specials that he's directed and I
was just like
blown away because I was like I I even
if I knew even if I had your contact
info and knew you I wouldn't have been
comfortable asking given who you've
directed specials for like he did like
he's done like worked for like Joe list
and Mark Normand and Sam Morel it's like
I'm really young and he just had a
couple months where I think it was just
you know there's this sort of ebb and
flow of when people are filming stuff
and he um and I and he he because I
already like had all the filming set up
what I should in hindsight I should have
told everyone not to bother coming and
just had him do the whole thing but I
didn't want to turn you know I'd already
said so so he agreed to just take all
the raw footage after the fact and uh
which makes his job even harder because
he wasn't in control of the filming and
he still did like an amazing job yeah
and I don't think I'm guessing if I do
another one he'll he'll probably be far
too busy to uh to do my next one because
um he's that good
but uh but you may be that big Adam well
we'll see hats off to Jason Katz though
and and uh I owe him a lot
um yeah
is there a tapping
are you typing me oh is that you yeah I
know yeah oh cool yeah so in the okay
cool yeah
very nice yeah that's dope that uh
Jason's willing to do that that's very
cool
yeah he's great
yeah collaborations all these
self-produced comedy specials end up
being like
such like a collaboration of some degree
I mean like the guy that directed mine
was a fan of the podcast oh awesome and
um I was like just talking about wanting
to do an album and he's like I could
help you film a special so then like and
then my friend in La who's in the film
business uh he flew in to man one of the
cameras as well oh wow um so it's just
like it takes a village to do these
things like you don't need to have
this huge setup or whatnot you can
really put something together that's
really high quality and you're special I
mean your special looks amazing you know
there are some out there that are like
but your special like has that
professional policy like if a Booker
sees it they're gonna be like oh okay he
like yeah
he looks professional he looks like
someone we would actually want to pay to
perform
yeah oh thank you yeah I was very happy
with the way it looked and it was a lot
it was a lot of fun
um definitely gets you like amped up to
just start writing to because you
because you want to do it again yep for
sure
and what um idiot on the comedy circuit
asked what was an unexpected obstacle
you ran into
oh
um
well someone told me they're like a week
before they're like Adam just write down
a list of all the things that could go
wrong
and assume that they all do and um
like um the guy who's one of the guys
was doing the sound uh for whatever like
the one the way that you would connect a
a digital recorder to this particular
soundboard was like the only connection
connect cable he didn't have
you know
um
so there was that that we needed and uh
just out of uh because out of an
abundance of caution I'd gone I'd done
some spots at the club the month leading
up to it and had uh
had brought my own like and for some
reason I don't know if I I
subconsciously anticipated it and I'd
looked at the sound board and I'd gone
on Amazon and I ordered every possible
cable
and I just had them in my bag so I Just
Whipped I'm like this so I did it that's
one of the things I was doing right
before I went on stage you know yeah
thank God because there was not enough
time to like go to Best Buy at that
point
um so that was one the um the woman
getting thrown out I guess but that's
during the show that's I'm on stage like
whatever uh yeah
and then all the problems with the sound
like I never thought about air
conditioning like we you know yeah we
got lucky that we got lucky with the
sound that could have been really bad
with the people in the audience did you
like the mix of your people and then
people that's never seen you before or
would you change that like what I guess
what would you do differently or did you
like that mix of
kind of
50 50 people and then sort of people
that you brought into the show
yeah it worked great because I would say
maybe it was like 25 where people that
knew me but a lot of them brought people
with them right so I think that was
great because there was at least 75
percent of the room had not heard any of
the material before you know what I mean
um yeah and when I was on stage and I
look at the front row which and you see
some of it from the in the special when
you you know um you see some of the
front row and we show the uh the
audience view I didn't know any of those
people
so also the way people were sat which
was not something that I had uh asked to
be done that way
but making sure that the front row or
even the front two rows isn't the people
I know
was really good like I don't want to see
the faces of of the people you know the
people I know I want them in the back
laughing and letting all that laugh come
forward and you know so that so the way
they were sat worked out really well as
well which that's just and that was just
luck
um
that's cool though but yeah it was a
good it was a good mix that way
yeah that's awesome
yeah there is of course is that like if
the people you don't know might not like
your comedy
[Laughter]
foreign
was all Juiced I think I knew basically
everyone I think a few okay a few family
a few friends of family
or like like people I didn't know but
like knew someone else going a few of
them came but mine was basically
and this was a small black box theater
it was the first place I ever headlined
like three years into my career when
you're like what am I even doing here
right now but you do it and then so it
was like 62 people I think very small so
it was like a venue that I felt
comfortable I was like oh I can call in
all the favors and like sell this out
uh that's great and and I did
I did like three tiers of tickets
so it's like I mean my whole goal with
the special was just to make my money
back so like I have
I made probably half back that night and
then have since made it back selling it
on the website
but it was I I basically I like
basically just called in all the favors
to actually sell out my way so it could
go it could go either way because
people knew me so they were super hyped
so if anyone has seen Barry cats roast
my comedy special then you know he
roasts this huge guy in the front row
who's taking up like a quarter of the
screen he's like what are you doing
there you can't you gotta seat people
that's gonna look like it just looked
weird but this guy he was a former
student he was so excited to be there he
sat front and center he'd been drinking
so after a lot of the things I was
saying he was like yeah or like you know
he was like super into it the audio's
not gonna pick it up most of the
audience isn't going to pick it up I
can't like tell him to like relax you
know so that's the other side of it of
inviting everyone and everyone knowing
you is that it could be over hyped and
they there may be distractions that way
as well so there's gonna be there's
gonna be hitches regardless of the route
you go
but um you're definitely bringing up a
lot of good things for people to prepare
ahead of time to think about
oh there's there's one uh there was one
comic that was going to come in support
and I had to talk and it was so awkward
because I had to talk because he has a
very weird loud laugh that's just no
mistake like and and he and he laughs at
some things that other people don't
necessarily laugh at and uh
I I was like hey I'd love for you to
come and support but just I can't I only
have one show
so if you come you just you can't be
that laugh
and he's like I understand and then he
didn't come
of course that's a good friend you know
absolutely and he was so sweet
afterwards he was like hey how'd it go
and he's like because you know he can't
help himself that's just his laugh yeah
but there would be there would be no
mistaking it um
on an audio recording
yeah
and Elijah said I watched and it was
well worth the watch or run in the
background
thank you
perfect yeah yeah it is it's definitely
funny I watched it again today I watched
it when it came out and I watched it
again today it is so funny uh and very
personal which I which I always love
with a community when you're learning a
lot about them and just great writing
well you're almost at 82 000 views right
now has anything I wouldn't be listening
did you yeah I said it's all lies but I
was just oh it's all lies
it's all true unfortunately MIT Finance
background I mean there's a lot of cool
unique things you draw from
um but uh have you gotten booked off
this like what's kind of the response
like 82 000 views you know and you're
sharing a lot on social media what kind
of have you got any bookings or like
what's kind of come of it would you say
well there's some Bookers that like when
it's come up when I've mentioned it
they've asked me to send them a link and
then and then they have booked me so
it's like was it because of that or you
know that had to have played uh
a role and just kind of like you know
legitimizing myself as as a professional
you know what I mean yeah
um and then there's there's one Club but
they haven't booked me yet but um they
asked for an unedited you know 25 minute
feature set to book features and this is
a this is let's just say it's a chain
that has multiple clubs and um I sent
them I sent them an unedited 62 minutes
and uh and you know they emailed me back
you know a few days later
um basically asking me a bunch of
questions about my schedule and stuff so
like knock on wood did something comes
of that
um
so there's that and then you know the
the uh being able to clip it up and
there's you know in
30 second increments there's probably a
third of it on Instagram reels and
YouTube shorts and
um getting whether that has enticed
people to watch the whole thing which
helps I I think that uh
I think the Bookers go to your Instagram
now before they go to your website so if
they're just it gives you know your
Instagram is a comedian I think it's
sort of like your it's basically your
resume
um
so it's hard like my sister my instinct
is that it has helped a lot
um just from a credibility standpoint
like there's something you can point to
that exists that anyone can go watch
and it's uh
and it's professionally done like you
know as opposed to like here's here's my
killer five minute tape which we all
need to have and we all want to have
um but it's like yeah here's that and
then here's this other thing too and you
don't even have to like
they don't even have to watch it it's
just knowing it exists I think gives
people a little more comfort
yeah and I think like
just the fact that you actually have
traction on it also like you said just
what life is that this is not like
you're not like a like a some overnight
success like you know what you're doing
like and you've had traction on this
special as well
right no I'm I'm yeah I mean the fact
that 80 000 people 80 2000 the fact that
81 976 not that I'm counting people
is um well it was 68 when I had it
pulled up so it's moving on up as we
speak I just made up that number but um
yeah
but yeah I know yeah the thing about
YouTube is each video is a is an asset
so it's like you create it once and now
it lives on the algorithm and it can
take off whenever so like yeah like you
said it's kind of gone up and then kind
of plateau and then it's like gone up
again like YouTube's crazy like that so
what was interesting it went up while I
was in Florida and I was wondering like
are these people seeing my feature set
and then watching you know all or part
of the special which is great yeah
because if if if I get more work and
then that creates like a Synergy within
they watch it great you know
um it also was like it also got my
YouTube to monetization
so that if I do post something on
YouTube now and it were to go viral I
could actually get paid for it which is
great
so yeah you know there's a lot of
and it's it's wild to look at the data
too like the analytics of like you can
see you can go back to like what cities
people are in that are watching it
um and it's it's pretty wild
um because if you see some City that's
like just has a big viewership then
maybe maybe you have a fan base there
yeah
like maybe you could go there and sell
out a black little black box theater or
something you know
um yeah but anyway so yeah
recorded it how long did it take you to
put it out like the recording all the
way to the time
it took
about three a little under three months
and um part of that is the director got
covered so that knocked him out for a
couple weeks
um I when he told me I had he had covet
I thought oh he'll get it done faster
because he's got to stay at home but it
turned out
it was a bad kind yeah I guess the kind
where he didn't want to do my special
while he was sick I couldn't believe it
but uh hilarious but it was like a three
month turnaround which you know isn't is
fine but also
um
you know I
not having gone through it before you
know he sends me a draft
right and then I get go back with like
30 pages of notes
um and we did that like four times and
uh
in hindsight I think I could I could
have been more efficient
as we like on the on the iterations
um but we you know we got there
that's awesome but I also think it just
depends on what other projects whoever's
editing it and or directing it it's just
whatever projects they're trying to do
simultaneously and what else is going on
in their life is going to be the biggest
determinant like if he had nothing else
to do he could do it in a couple weeks
it's not you know it's just
you know it takes a little time
for sure
and then I also didn't you know I didn't
want I didn't want to release it in the
second half of August I just felt like
it's a sleepy time I was like at this
point let's just wait till September
and uh release it like after Labor Day
or whatever I don't know if that makes
any difference but
Elijah asked did you did you run any ads
for like the trailer promoting it or did
you did you think to do that
I did I I did the trailer and like three
or four Clips were like the proper kind
of horizontal type videos and I put them
on Facebook and I promoted them so I had
like a little budget in mind of what I
was willing to do with that because I
talked to a few other people that had
put stuff out on YouTube and uh and
they'd kind of given me they had done
some Facebook ads that had sort of
worked and uh
yeah when I look at the analytics I'm
just get it's like it does it doesn't
say this person was like a clicked on
the Facebook link but there's a sort of
other links category and just if I look
at it my guess is maybe eight to ten
thousand views came from Those ads
but also if those ads helped get people
to it in those first few weeks then that
helps the algorithm that makes the
algorithm show to other people too you
know what I mean
um you just want there to be that surge
of demand in the first few weeks that
makes the computer be like oh people
like this thing with people are watching
this thing let's show it to everybody
um because the percentage of people when
you look at how people found it
a very high percentage of it is
suggested videos which means they're
watching something else and my thing and
my specialist suggested
and then they watch it and they watch it
for like an average of 20 to 25 minutes
so that's that's something oh that's
great
yeah
oh wow
that's great for a video that long
and I think most people watch these
things in chunks even if they watch the
whole thing very few people sit through
a whole 60-minute comedy special these
days right you know yeah they even I
think that was um I think Bert Kreischer
said that about his Netflix special was
he put like his best joke in the middle
because yeah Netflix had said people are
bailing at this time and it was around
like the 25 minute Mark so yeah you see
that translate to YouTube as well
well you see like like um Sam morel's
recent Netflix special was like 40
minutes on the dot and um
you know I think the days of people like
I kind of it was more just my ego I
wanted to put out something as close to
an hour as I could just to say that I
did it and and right you know proved him
but
even like a 30 minute special is if it's
funny people love it you don't need it
doesn't need to be an hour
if it's 30 minutes and it feels like
it's like that's the material you want
to do and it feels like it's supposed to
be that and it it's good it's great you
don't need you know do it
that's interesting to do Facebook ads
for a YouTube video did you have like a
link in the description or like what was
like the did you have a call to action
at the end of the video like how do you
get people to jump ship from Facebook
well what I I mean remember how I did
this what I did is on my Facebook uh
how did I do it
I think what I did was on my on like my
Facebook kind of Adam Mueller comedy
page I put the video up
and then
um
I would put the link in the comments I
think
and then I would then I would promote it
well I'd sh then I'd go to my like
regular page and I'd find it and I'd
share it
and promote it and on the promotion
you can steer it to a website
and I would just own the web section
button yeah and that button would take
it and that that website would be the
YouTube would be the YouTube I think
that's how I did it gotcha
okay yeah that would make sense then
some it was something like that
um yeah yeah I like I like recorded mine
and then released it and then was like
now what like I didn't even think that
far ahead so I think that's another
thing
I would have thought of as well as like
pre-production production
post-production and like all right how
you gonna Market this thing like there's
and when you're doing your budget before
you even shoot it allocate some money to
marketing
anything about any of that yeah yeah
so and my mark my marketing was just my
time on Insta like dming people and then
uh and then the Facebook ads and that
was most of it
um
yeah it's legit dude
yeah way yeah so people go watch Adam's
special it is linked in the description
yeah
Master Class
what does it uh
um so should we do some joke feedback
would you say
let's go is there uh and Adam if you
need to leave
I know oh I'll hang out I'm good I took
up the hour you're good oh yeah yeah I
I'm I'm good my man okay I just want to
be respectful I appreciate it
um nice let me just start rerunning my
special in the background again I keep
it up
[Laughter]
is there is there any um for someone
that listened to this
and it's like oh maybe I want to do this
is there or like is there any how did
you know you were ready or like what
what is like the closing advice for
someone listening to this that maybe
Wednesday wants to produce their own
special
do you have anything to kind of leave
them with
well the mo like when I realized I think
I can I think I can stand up there and
tell jokes for an hour was one you know
a weekend of being in my room I grew up
playing
holding holding a mic staring at the
wall with the stopwatch on and and I
told jokes and the thing got to like an
hour and 20 minutes and I was like oh I
have enough
now I just need to figure out like what
what's the order you know what don't
what what do I cut
you know you know and then and then
there's something about having that flag
in the ground you get like a month in a
couple weeks in you just start writing
like new stuff and just starts coming to
you because you because of the pressure
of having to do the hour
so there's a couple things in there that
worked really well there was there's one
thing that was written like three days
before that was for the hour that I had
never said before
um and that that's the uh that's the
Marvel joke
and that thing that popped up I I was
playing your special that was so I'm
sorry nice nice thanks I appreciate the
view you interrupt us as much
was special for the rest of this hour
how about that yeah
I wanted to put a joke in where I
acknowledge that I'm this is all one
take
the chances of this working are like you
know yeah so I wrote a joke for that
knowing that I could only try it once
and if it just didn't work I would just
have to cut it I guess
yeah but it worked
that's awesome yeah great advice yeah so
go watch Adam's special everyone and uh
we're gonna jump into some
joke feedback here and we will keep them
uh
we'll keep them tight we'll keep them
tight here fam
let's let's keep them tight
um
and I'll bring them up on screen I was
trying to find the timer because I'm in
the three-person view I'm not used to um
let me see
not used to this one
and no sound effects gosh half the fun
was gonna be Adam
um hahaha
all right all right
it's the best
um one second
one second we're almost there
boom
yeah all right there it is okay I had to
get the timer going
um
still good every time
[Laughter]
all right so thank you all for hanging
out man we're at 31 people right now an
hour in this is incredible
yeah
so let's get to some joke feedback here
the first one up
is from wasallu Gus
uh his joke is
YT people
are in white people white people
probably
all right just a good start white people
are interesting in a sense where they
build spice racks but don't use
seasoning white people go to the doctor
the only time ethnic people go to the
doctor is when they have to give birth
okay
um
spice racks but don't use seizing yeah
it's like two separate jokes essentially
so I would be more interested if it was
more personal to like my white friend
does this but I do that type deal just
to make it a little more personal
yeah or just funnier
um
I wish red sound effects
so I think I I kind of see where they're
going I think the problem is that
there's no punch line you're just saying
the sort of the obvious thing that the
only time they go to the doctor is to
give birth and that's one of those
things like when you give a punchline
like that you got to make it interesting
enough for it to be separate than what
you were saying like
you go to the doctor to give birth like
what else is interesting when you go to
the doctor that'd be my only thing is
like it just didn't pop
um
given this setup the very long setup too
thoughts Adam
would you put this one I guess I I think
there's something funny about the idea
that like if you had like my wife my
white friend made a spice rack in shop
class
and I was like what do you do I've
tasted your cooking you don't need that
like there's something funny about yeah
about that
um especially if you make it a little
more personal and then um
I know I feel like ethnic people maybe a
specific ethnicity or your ethnicity
and if they're if there's a way to to
make that a little more interesting
because it makes me think like why do
they only go to the doctor
you're gonna have to give birth but but
if that's true there is there's there's
something funny about that idea
but it's also why people go to the
doctor maybe why go people go to the
doctor if they slept badly or like for
you know there's some specific
non-critical reason
the only time you know my people
whatever that whatever that would be go
to the doctor is blank anyway but I
think both of those could be great jokes
about those ideas
just separated out into two separate
jokes
and then make it a bit more pers make it
a bit more personal to you rather than
just ethnic groups because that could be
anything or any group
nice
all right
gosh regrets no we're I'm grateful to be
here I'm gonna stop saying it
all right I'm sorry
grateful okay here we go by Harold
you know what really annoys me people
praise for lacking commitments recently
a failed suicide bomber blew up on
YouTube I was Furious but at least he
finally dedicated his life to something
sometimes
I don't know if this is like a double
entender with the suicide bomber blowing
up on YouTube like in terms of like
subscriber or is it more
like because if that's it I feel like
that should be the punch line
like that should be go towards the end
of the joke
and then the question up top I would
just rephrase it to just I get annoyed
for p at people that get praise for lack
of commitment rather than say it in a
question at people
it wasn't my only two yeah
I think you could do something like um
recently a failed suicide bomber blew up
Tick Tock
I mean blew up on Tick Tock it was the
best uh
you know best dance I've ever seen
something like that you just play with
you could play with the words a bit
for sure
yeah I think just overall like the the
setup doesn't match like he's like what
annoys me is people praise for lacking
commitment and then there's not really
an example of someone
praise for lacking commitment
you know what I mean that I don't want
the premise almost seems disconnected
from the actual joke
I think that's what slightly confused me
but uh overall cool
nice
um so just know
in between and after we read every joke
my brain is thinking I wish we had sound
effects so I'm not going to keep saying
it
all right let's do it
I just want everyone
um so I don't so I stopped saying it
um
all right chance my girlfriend died a
couple weeks ago so I used a Ouija board
to contact her and let her know I still
love and miss her
but she ghosted me she replied new phone
who diss
all right
I see where the joke is going
um
I feel like you should be sadder that
your girlfriend died yeah
but uh wouldn't it be new Ouija board
who dis
s ooh new Ouija board who it is
that's kind of funny yeah
yeah I and I like new Ouija board who
this more than the ghost did
yes um or I like that one first and then
maybe the ghosted
um unless the ghost that admit this
maybe have done before my my girlfriend
ghosted me a few weeks ago she died
that's hilarious I actually didn't go to
the and then go to the Ouija board joke
and then you you maybe get two good
laughs
I love that
yeah I love that you know what that is
that's such a New York approach to
writing that joke
Adam style because
um a couple of times and he doesn't
[__] mince words like that's what I
like about New York comedians it's like
you guys just running short bits that
you got to get funny like quickly so
like I feel like a little bit in the
South we can get away with like talking
much longer before we get to our
punchlines versus you guys up in New
York you're like no we got three minutes
and we gotta get as many last as
possible yeah in these units so like
your whole approach to the joke is like
uh how many of these words can we just
remove out of the way
yeah but that's solid I love that yeah I
love reordering it that way
um Zeb Valentine
joke I was once sunburned so bad I was
red as a lobster had a fever and the
Shivers my family called me the Scarlet
twitch
I don't know where twitch comes in
like I think the Shivers it's the witch
oh because he had the Shivers oh okay
yeah I this is one of those that I think
might work better as a tweet than as a
joke on stage because I'm not sure if
people would get it
like
from a performance perspective right
yeah
or what about like my my red-headed
friend is an epileptic we call him the
Scarlet twitch
yeah that's those thing in the twitch
should be more connected to like the
setup instead of like this glancing
detail you know I feel like the twitch
should
have more relevance that's what I was
thinking like he had Tourette's or
something
yeah that's what I thought about twitch
too but then I realized it was the witch
part
but this might be one of those cases of
being a little too clever rather than
clear
oh yeah yeah I mean yeah the whole joke
is basically a word play like it all
builds up to this silly word play that
may or may not be true anyway
yeah
um he said they don't get it when I do
it on stage well there you go
foreign
sounds like you got something you're on
to something there Zeb
um all right all right maybe it's just
to simplify it just said it was once
sunburned so bad I started shaking
they called me the Scarlet twitch
oh yeah yeah
that's cleaner yeah yeah and if you do
this
twitch part maybe you actually twitch
like I think yeah you'd give him a
active yeah give him a little shiver as
well
because I think that may elevate the
joke as well
noise
thanks Zeb
um oh we have another ghost a joke this
one is
um let me see
this one's in our face special everyone
um a woman oh okay this is Elijah
a woman Reese I recently ghosted nuke
feedback
oops all right a woman recently ghosted
me but she keeps liking my Instagram
post so not only did I get ghosted now
I'm being haunted
I like the word I haven't heard that
take on ghosting before that was
different I chuckled
I wonder if there's a way to do it will
you only say ghosted once
like uh a woman stopped returning my
calls but she keeps liking my Instagram
posts so she so not only did I get
ghosted now I'm being haunted
something like that so you only have to
say ghosted once yeah or instead of
ghosted I got haunted or instead of
getting ghosted I got haunted something
like that yeah or I didn't just get
ghosted I got haunted or yeah
yeah it's a good point but I don't I
feel like you have to say ghosted first
to them punch
oh
you know what I mean so maybe just don't
say it the second time go see it but she
keeps liking my posts so now I'm being
haunted yeah yep
boom that's why we do it kids
all right and then you can say something
like so I like her likes
so now now she's being
stalked or I don't know whatever the
word
yeah oh right right you flip it flip it
back like there's a there's got to be a
tag there
that's a good point can you like
someone's likes on Instagram I don't
even know if you can but
but that's I like the flipping it though
um next
memory
you want to read this one Yoshi
milk was so expensive when I was growing
up when my dad tried to get one he had
to make a second family just to have
enough household income to afford it
that's funny
um
I don't get it because wouldn't having a
second family be even more expensive
than having one family
but that's the point of the milk that it
was so expensive that he had to
distribute it to the second family
so at that point that point I got to
your point though I think
is this that does this feel true enough
because in your mind you're like a
second family feels expensive in my mind
I was stuck on the fact that milk was
expensive so we have two interpretations
of it
um so it may not be clear enough on
which one's more expensive
you know
that's a tough one
that is a good point though it could be
interpreted two different ways
growing up milk was so expensive my dad
had to have a second family just to
afford it
yeah I guess just logically though it
doesn't line up
maybe it's just not afford it maybe he
had to have a second family to
distribute it
or he he had to like get rid of his
second family just to afford it so maybe
it's like ah
could be something that way as well so
instead of having a second family he
actually had to leave his second family
I think that would hit harder yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah milk was so
expensive my father had to leave his
second family just to afford it
there we go yes very funny
oh my gosh Bob Kirk said
it's cheaper when you have two lactating
moms
no I think that was just a tag but
that's hilarious
that is incredible
oh my gosh
um
Neil Prettyman
uh wait he he posted twice
all right I'll I'll look at the second
one maybe he refined the second one
um I'm confused why the deaf haven't
figured out how to listen to music hear
me out Ah that's insensitive listen
close wait I got it read my lips vinyl
records are just Sonic Braille
um
[Music]
instead of instead of the the joke being
about why they haven't figured it out
maybe the joke is like how they figured
it out
so it's not like I'm confused why they
haven't figured it out it's like I'm
surprised the death figured out how to
listen to music
and then whatever the surprising twist
is there
yeah and I mean like even the hear me
out I like just pausing between those
rather than going oh that's insensitive
hear me out I mean listen close I mean
read my lips I prefer that over like oh
that's insensitive because now you're
calling attention to it
but just the vinyl records are just
Sonic Braille
I don't it just doesn't hit
this feels like he thought of the phrase
Sonic Braille and was like yeah let's go
get them you know sometimes we think of
like words together and we're like yeah
we're gonna shoehorn that in somewhere
but it made
it may just be a long way to get to say
Sonic Braille
oh Lance Stewart said that joke was
bumpy speaking of Braille laughs
I feel like the roasts are better than
the jokes
all right
it's so good that's so good
I mean the joke the joke I would think
of would be something like I uh
I saw my deaf cousin like just
touching a vinyl record I was like what
I said I signed what are you doing and
he said I'm listening
but yeah and I like I like that angle is
more personal too I don't know if it's
yeah I don't know if that would work but
it could be fun
I just feel like I've heard something
like that before about feeling the
grooves in a record as Braille
but I don't I don't know where
it's very possible
very possible but yeah I like yours I
like your spin on it better just
personalizing it you know
and personalizing it by making up a
cousin that's what I like to do yeah
exactly but now there's like a person
now the audience yeah there's a real
connection to what you're doing yeah
yeah
um good point
uh Mary Elizabeth
Donuts the only time you can eat a cold
hole out of a closed box without it
being considered abuse of a corpse
[Laughter]
doesn't like a good necrophilia joke
oh
[Laughter]
I mean
it's all there
that joke kills
Sunshine is dead to rights
um I mean the only thing it's really
missing is like some kind of
personalness but honestly I mean
got everything there it's not bad
I don't know what the cold whole part is
yeah you do
[Laughter]
you know exactly what that is
[Music]
Adam said that like
I think he was a detective you know
[Laughter]
that's so funny I grew up playing in a
hawk oh my gosh this special start
playing in the background again
gosh that's so funny
yeah you'll have to bring back uh Buck
Sweeney for that one there Adam oh for
sure you know
work on the prequel
um nice well you got some laughs there
uh
Mary nicely done
um you know
um it's Akuma
when I hear someone mention inflation I
imagine a politician putting their thumb
and their mouth and blowing their head
up like a balloon get it because I think
a lot of them are
Airheads
oh is that like when you pinch your nose
and and like pop your ears or whatever I
guess so
I
yeah I think it could just call them
instead of someone
because he said politicians maybe it's
like when I hear politicians mention
inflation
or politicians are AirHeads all they
talk about is inflation
or
something that way
just something yeah quicker and to the
point more
whenever here politician mentioned
inflation I just think what an airhead
but I was definitely excited for overall
joke
uh feedback don't ever put the words get
it in the middle of your joke I would
say maybe maybe leave that part out
and when you say it then you're like get
it
right guy right
[Laughter]
cool that's like basically saying the
punch line is coming guys and there it
is
Felix oh and Jose Salomon from Peru
what's goody fam
stand-up comedy arakipa uh that's my
that's my favorite joke yet
me trying to speak Spanish hello
everyone I'm from Peru I think that's
hysterical that's awesome great that's a
great opener Jose you should open great
opener yeah
sure I love that how cool and I had a
comic DM me from Tokyo today oh wow we
out you in these three top breath verse
it's a worldwide himself
and Felix Felix actually
I actually shared a clip of Felix today
when he he
joined the live stream last time and
said this show inspired him to um get on
stage for the first time
awesome
they recently did a study that found if
you have depression that same mental
chemistry can be passed down to your
kids
if you beat them hard enough
[Music]
oh my heavens
I don't hate it
I don't hate it this is probably
triggering for a lot of people it's
definitely triggered me
I think maybe you could simplify it
though and just say like a study found
that depression can be passed on to your
kids if you beat them hard enough
yeah yeah that's kind of fun
I like it yeah but and keeping that
pause in there yeah your kids pause if
you beat them hard enough
yeah yeah a nice little uh nice little
genetic misdirect there yeah like that
you put the pause right after if you
beat them and just leave it maybe even
adjust before hard enough if you beat
them just hard enough
is there and that could become a tag
there of like like pass down to your
kids pause if you beat them pause just
hard enough hard enough like there could
be like the punchline of beat them and
then that pause could then create the
tag for that just hard enough you have
to play around with it
um but overall the joke seems to be
there
solid yeah I like that well done
uh it doesn't work with other people's
kids though
oh my that's a hilarious tag it's got to
be your kids yeah you start beating
other people's kids you just get in
trouble
yeah he was in jail yeah
keto Carol here we go
I think I'd rather like
all right uh with my deep voice people
assume I'm a spokesperson for Chantix
I'm not a smoker I did experiment for
nine months but I quit as soon as I was
born
it was too hard to hold cigs in my baby
hands oh that's a great Mr Right
[Laughter]
child abuse to really level up this live
stream I think you could start right
with the smoker part right like I'm not
a smoker but I did experiment for nine
months I quit as soon as I was born
yeah that's just that's great yeah yeah
and then the tag is just yeah that's a
funny joke
yeah your your mother might not like it
but uh that's funny it could be a tag
and the Saints get back as well yeah so
just reorder that
what is Chantix
it's like a crowd to help you quit
smoking oh okay like nicotine I think or
yeah so people would need to know that
context as well they need to know
Chantix
for that joke well you could just say if
if you have a very deep voice and you
want to address it you could just say
with my deep voice people assume I'm a
smoker
I experimented for nine months but I
quit as soon as I was born boom
yeah yeah I like I like that makes it
much tighter there
that's a that's funny
nice
oh she said the Chantix line always gets
a laugh yeah well then you could um that
could then become a tag because I like
Adam reworking it so like with my deep
voice people assume I'm a smoker but I
don't like experimented for nine months
and quit as soon as I was born
or something like that you did right
yeah and then Chantix could be a tag at
the end of that instead of in the middle
perhaps
nice I like that though that's a great
mystery quitting as soon as you're born
um
another tag could be something like but
I but I but I'm still a booze bag
oh right right right right like you know
so she's not like the health she's it's
not like she's any healthier
yeah or
um was like as a bae I quit when I was a
baby like I was a baby I couldn't hold
the cigarettes but uh I could you know I
could still hold the bottle oh no or I'm
just trying to imply that her mother was
also drinking during pregnancy
oh yeah yeah like
I quit I quit the cigarettes as soon as
I was born but I just kept on but I
stayed on the booze
yeah
yeah I even thought like the uh I
couldn't hold more Burrows but I could
hold Marlboro Lights or like just using
the light version of the cigarette and
be like Oh but my mom gave me marble
lights because that's the younger kids
version or something
um yeah
Jessica
I am too old for Tinder in other dating
apps I just flipped through the old
Rolodex on date nights
I mean it's a gorilla dick it's just
what you know
[Laughter]
I deserved that
oh hilarious
God that's so good
[Laughter]
that's so good
I mean do people have to know what a
Rolodex is to get that
I think I mean probably they'd have to
know what Rolodex is all I would say is
that
end on Rolodex yeah it's like on date
night I just flip through the old
Rolodex
yeah yep just to end on the actual punch
word but I like the word play people do
need to know what Rolodex is but I think
if they do they would get that yeah and
also think I'm just saying I'm too old
for Tinder is enough you don't have to
mention the other dating apps oh yeah
good call or even I'm just too old for
dating apps so on date night I just flip
through my old Rolodex
laughs
like how you said that that's a new
sound
[Laughter]
effects all right laughs
um
Ty Erskine
I just got engaged last week I spent my
whole life savings on that ring man all
799 dollars and 32 cents
so the joke is basically he's broke
like his life savings was basically 800
I guess that's the joke
um
but it's not a big enough twist it's
like the life savings would have to be
like 7.99
or like his what if his life savings
wasn't even money
what if his life savings was like this
ring he inherited from his grandmother
or
um
or I spent my whole life savings on that
Cracker Jack box
yeah something like that
yeah something made in money
or um
or or he got the ring out of a quarter
machine
because all he had was a quarter like it
needs to be more absurd
yeah it doesn't even more absurd because
I think yeah the money aspect either has
to be like
ridiculous like 7.99 or even like 79
cents
um
or I'm trying to think if is there a
word play on ring that you could do
like if you said I spent my entire life
savings on that ring
and now I watch her everywhere every
time she leaves the house so that's a
thought like just you I'm saying like
the ring doorbell yeah yeah yeah yeah
Mr right there yeah
I like that
cool well thanks for sharing there Ty
uh mudit Verma
I got spanked as a kid until my parents
made me get braces they finally stopped
not because they're good people but to
avoid paying dental repairs
good God
I'm not a good child abuse today
um only thing that kind of took me off
is like when I think of spanking I think
of like getting hit like on the butt
versus like getting hit as a kid
may help fit better for the dental
repairs you know I'm saying so that was
the only thing that I would connect
those two with
so it could be my my parents hit me
until I was old enough to get braces
yeah not because they're good people but
to avoid paying dental repairs you
that's brutal your parents are punching
you in the mouth yeah it's pretty it's
pretty gnarly though yeah that's funny
[Laughter]
cool there's something there's something
funny to that idea though the parents
would stop hitting you because now
they've tried to fix something about you
because the braces are to straighten
your teeth and the hitting is to
straighten your attitude or something
like that
you know
oh yeah Neil said hit me until my baby
teeth fell out
oh
nice
um cool beans
we're bringing up a lot of childhood
issues for people there's a lot a lot of
childhood issues coming through here
[Laughter]
um oh my heavenly day Lance Stewart
this one's yours sometimes my white
friends are way too proud of what ethnic
percentage they are my friends are like
I'm 1 16th Cherokee Indian and I'm like
yeah probably by force
yeah
is everybody okay
yeah yeah
this isn't therapy we should clarify
that we are not licensed uh therapist
here
but we are licensed comedians so
whatever you feel like we can oh God
that is interesting I worked with a
comic this weekend who had kind of a
similar joke about
uh like getting 23andMe to find out he
was like a like 1 18th Cherokee Indian
or something so it's interesting how the
premise is carrying over here
um
yeah I have a joke similar to this but
it takes on a different approach
but my wife
yeah
I mean I see the joke
I don't I don't know if I have any real
what if there's another way to say it
that just softens it a bit
but you might not want to
it's like when a white it's maybe it's
like when a white person finds out their
1 16th Cherokee Indian
they might want to keep them to that
keep that to themselves because that
wasn't consensual I don't know like
there's some
yeah there's some other way to say it
you know yeah it's like instead of
bragging about it maybe you should think
about how that might have happened
oh yeah I like that some that kind of an
angle to it because it's
like stop and think how did how did that
happen before you applied to open your
Casino
do something
there's a tag there
yeah
all right
um
idiot on the comedy circuit
I was told people in love can
synchronize their heart
I told the person to f off my wife
wasn't pleased
now because she disagreed but she not
because she disagreed
but she hates it when I swear at my 10
year old
I should read that again I was told
people in love can synchronize their
heartbeats I told the person to f off my
wife wasn't pleased not because she
disagreed but she hates it when I swear
at my 10 year old
okay
so it's the point that they love that
their 10 year old and not their wife is
that the idea
I don't know is that they're
I think it's just that the 10 year old
letting theirs have synchronized
Heartbeats
I think that's what I was trying to set
up that he was telling his wife to f off
but it was really his child I think
that's the misdirect he's going for
I was told people and love can
synchronize our heartbeats I told that
person to f off
so I mean if you're going for that
misdirect it could be but my wife said
don't talk to our child that way
so like yeah I told the person to f off
and my wife said don't talk to our
daughter that way
yeah I think that'd be better and then
also I feel like instead of just telling
that person the F off it should just be
like a bit more specific
I told that person to get the F out of
my face or like like just be more
specific so like it's visually just the
categorical F off it just doesn't seem
to hit
but I like your edit Joel of just
my wife wasn't pleased and told us not
to speak to our daughter that way
yeah yeah
nice
um
next up we have Bobby looks like we just
have a few more here
let's see how many deeper issues we can
get into before
if I could have like four left here
um
I find my husband's sleep apnea
fascinating but I have to be careful
observing him
not uh it's just a funny line not
breathing for a minute is an experiment
not breathing for over four minutes is
considered negligent homicide
observing him I was thinking it was
going in the direction observing him of
like getting caught staring at him or
something but uh
while my husband's sleeping and
fascinating but I have to be careful
I think like the not breathing part
takes me out of it whereas
watching him for a minute is an
experiment watching him over four
minutes is considered negligent homicide
yeah or involuntary manslaughter yeah
um
I like that
yeah instead of the not breathing I
think watching yeah yeah
because you yeah sorry
instead of being careful observing him
maybe it's something like
but now I
think fascinating I S I have to be
careful studying him if she finds it
fascinating maybe she's studying him
um
I don't know there
yeah yeah I like the study
of just my husband's sleep ass apnea is
fascinating
I studied watching him for a minute
that's an experiment watching him over
four minutes that's considered a
negligible or you know involuntary
manslaughter but yeah I think the
watching is better
nice she said yeah go into the whole bit
on stage very nice
all right
cool beans all right
Adam's like what did I get myself into
he's like y'all do this every week
for free what are you guys insane
what do you want to do this is I'm not
getting paid for this
Adam I think that every week
yeah every week I'm like so we're still
doing this for free huh okay
we literally we just me and Joe just
keep calling favors into each other
each week we have to convince ourselves
all right it's your turn to break down
Joel you can do this buddy
um no we love all of you
yeah we do
uh
[Laughter]
Joey Ponce
did you guys see the video of Paul
Pelosi getting hit with a hammer pretty
messed up right still better than the
last Thor movie though
all right let's see where that's going
um
I feel like Thor hammer right yeah
yeah
take it out of question for him and it
might hit a little better
yeah instead of asking the question like
say it
yeah
so it's like the video of Paul Pelosi
getting hit with a hammer was pretty
messed up
but still better than the last Thor
movie
yeah
cool
all right we're fading should we just
stop
maybe no
this is what you signed up for
we're not doing the right thing Club
tomorrow
[Laughter]
no right 10 tomorrow
is that why
oh you know why
[Music]
we really Gotta Type we gotta get it
done in an hour we can't keep going over
like this we gotta it's the joke
feedback hour like we really we need to
keep it to an hour
dude but is this
Mr Miller over there was giving us some
comedy gems so that was worth the hour
by itself
so maybe that's part of
oh we got a super chat from Pamela okay
99 Cents we're back at it baby that
makes it all worth it we're back in it
thank you Pamela
in the game
that was our love language it was 99
Cents I feel like a Str I feel like
we're a stripper
and like someone just like flicked a
dollar coin on the stage we've been up
there for like
an hour and a half and they're like
there you go no but we really appreciate
that Pamela sincerely oh and a dollar 49
thank you Pamela
if I had sound effects we'd do one for
you but we appreciate it
um
you're getting fade plans have changed
around here Adam we're on the up and up
now
um but we're down to like the lat we may
be on the last one two Jerry Kroll
my Grandpa died five years ago but
grandma said she saw him in an Indian
restaurant last week I told her she was
losing it Grandpa hated Indian food
just
laughs
I think we're all trying to get it
there's something that's lost in the
translation I guess Grandpa Hagen Indian
food isn't like a big enough twist
yeah right I feel like it would need to
be Grandpa hated Indian people I think
is where it would have to really level
up
Grandpa was racist
there's no but there's no way he would
he was there he was racist I don't know
yeah
um
or just like the misdirected maybe
Grandpa didn't die maybe he just well
that's what I was thinking maybe he was
there yeah
um
so Jerry's the wrong one so it's like
she was right and he was wrong
yeah maybe
or maybe it's like I told her she was
losing it and then I called grandpa I
said you're gonna have to find a new
restaurant
he's in on it he's in on the fact that
his Grandpa took off you know
you gotta stop going to that Indian
place what other food did you tell her
you didn't like she's on to you Grandpa
she's on to you yeah stick to the Korean
barbecue place Grandpa
or hibachi yeah yeah yeah yeah stick to
Hibachi
that's a funny twist I like that
uh and this looks like the final one
here Gents
oh no Pamela because Pamela gave us a
Super Chat
I may actually have a bit
of both ADHD and autism sure I get real
easily distracted but mainly about color
coordination
I thought maybe like I get easily
distracted by trains
yeah it rolls better than color
coordination
um
and we don't need sugar so I'm easily
distracted
Pause by whatever this twist is we'll
find and I don't think actually I think
you should say I have a bit I would be
assertive
I have both ADHD and autism I get easily
distracted by trains or whatever the
thing is going to be
um that's a good point yeah yeah I was
actually for some reason I was thinking
I get ease I have a ADHD and autism I
get equally distracted by sentences
like just another fun thing another fun
thing could be not to finish the joke
just be I get easily distracted by
yeah yeah
that'd be a funny thing yeah and just
not even finish it
where he doesn't have social cues
right so maybe the tag could be he's
distracted he's like sorry I don't have
good social cues and that could be the
autism part
I can also Imagine like I get easily
distracted because I might have a bit of
ADHD and autism I get easily distracted
because I might have a bit of ADHD and
autism I get easily just like just
repeating it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then just at the end go also I have
short-term memory problems yeah
where was I where do I say
we were on the final joke
Pamela Galvez
all right everyone lean in Adam's back
into it now he's like all right the
final joke okay here we go 49 made all
the difference
we always talk about white privilege but
when I witnessed my white boyfriend pale
skin sunburn Sizzle and crackle oh no
you can keep that crackling skin burn
privilege for yourselves
cool Gucci yeah it's like an emoji it
described it literally in the live
stream
I like where it's going I like that it's
a joke about like white privilege
actually like being a burden or like it
being a problem you know so I like
flipping that stereotype on its head
I actually thought maybe snap crackle
and pop like oh be a better phrase I saw
his skin snap crackle and pop you can
keep that to yourself kind of thing
or maybe the word cracker came from how
the skin
cracks in the sun something like that
maybe
as possible
I told him not to let his testicles see
the sun
oh yeah so the sunburn could be in a
crazy place oh yeah that's a good point
it could be something like that told not
to sunbathe nude yeah I don't know good
point
cool
yeah sounds so painful
uh quite privilege
but my white boyfriend's sunburn
yeah
crackling sunburn I think you just take
out some words
keep that crackling skin burn privilege
for yourselves
uh being white is a privilege until they
get in the Sun
sick burn bro
sick
all right I think we did it
was that the last one
yes
[Laughter]
RG said I recently read that 70 of body
heat is lost through the head that
sounds like you could go skiing naked if
you had a good hat
yeah that was the last one yeah that was
the last one all right
well great job everyone
depends which head though doesn't it oh
there we go there you go RG
depends on which head good point
there you go some joke that was worth it
all right there with some hats you don't
even feel it
all right
here we go so do we take like five
minutes before the next hour and a half
or is it
let's do this all over again yeah so oh
Pamela just hit us with another 99 Cents
thank you for the Super Chat
oh my god well we do this every Tuesday
thank you to everyone that hung out with
us goodness we're still at 25 people
almost two hours into this
um so thank you all for hanging out we
do this every Tuesday
tell your friends and our
very gracious guest Adam Mueller go
check out his YouTube special thanks for
having me wow it's a link I'll be
looking at the view as soon as I get off
I'm going to look at the views I hope
I hope it's spiking yeah
we're all gonna need a spike after this
one uh there's at least five from Joe
accidentally turning it on
[Laughter]
[Music]
Bob Kirk said good to see you Adam hey
good to see you too Bob or talk to you
or see you typing whatever it's good
[Music]
appreciate you all hanging out with us
yeah
we'll be back next Tuesday at 5 p.m we
love you all so much
yeah Angel's on y'all angels on you I
appreciate you Adam thank you yeah
thanks for having me
all right guys love you
bye
damn
Adam you got a dad I don't know what
that is what are you doing hey dab all
right